demain soir au palais des congrès à
paris consécration ou déception ce sera
le lot d'un certain nombre de comédiens
metteurs en scène et de films moment de
la remise des oscars à la française de
ces oscars qui sont les césar sont des
petites statuettes qui symbolise le
choix par des professionnels des oeuvres
et des hommes qui auront marqué la vie
cinématographique en france cette année
une soirée qui sera retransmise en
direct sur antenne 2 à partir de 20h30
elle porte un joli nom la nuit des césar
les vingt statues de bronze doré qui
vont être décerné demain on était conçue
par le sculpteur césar il vous a
expliqué le symbole qui lie amis je
crois qu'à une partie concrètes dans sa
sculpture qui est ce personnage
enroulait de pellicule de film est
perché sur une roue qui est un peu la
roue de la fortune
mais qui à l'ap quand même une route
projecteurs août c'est une vieille
bobine de film mais il vous expliquer
pourquoi il a la tête chez les non ça il
n'a pas expliqué je crois que ça ne
s'explique pas il faut pas chercher à le
comprendre
et pourquoi a t'il la tête si petit
temps le cinéma on a plutôt des grosses
têtes
écoutez il n'a pas de bras il a une
petite tête moi qu'il faut demander à
césar ce qu'il a voulu déloger tous les
spectateurs qui seront là de m'asseoir
attendront qu'on proclame les gagnants
et chacun s'étonne qu'on ne les
connaissent pas déjà il ya un vote
secret qui est fait par l'ensemble de la
profession c'est à dire les membres de
l'académie des arts et techniques du
cinéma ils sont bien personnes 900 950
qui vote qui envoient leurs bulletins à
un huissier maître car syndic est un
outil assermentés qui les met sur
ordinateur
et qui recueillera les résultats de
l'ordinateur demain dans la journée qui
mettra le gagnant le nom du gagnant dans
une enveloppe apportera les traits
enveloppe demain soir à 20h30 sur la
scène du palais des congrès où nous
sommes en ce moment l an pendant
quelques heures seul lui sied connaîtra
le résultat celui ci connaîtra les
résultats c'est à dire que le gagnant ou
la gagnante la meilleure actrice
meilleur acteur le meilleur metteur en
scène sora qu'il est le gagnant en même
temps que les téléspectateurs de
m'asseoir